es hat was von schaulaufen
die große politik präsident und kanzler
kandidaten auch die kanzlerin kommt und
bundesminister aller art mit
landesfürsten ins katastrophengebiet
sie wollen sich ein bild machen und ein
bild abgeben von sich selbst trost
spenden und hilfe versprechen es ist
immer auch ein wettlauf um die
wählergunst die bundestagswahl ist nah
und das katastrophen geplagte wahl volk
herausgefordert also ich sag mal werden
als nüchtern betrachtete ich bin
ingenieur die sind eigentlich am
schreibtisch in den planungsbüros besser
aufgehoben aber tatsächlich muss auch
ein bisschen der focus hierhin gelenkt
werden insofern ist das glaube ich der
übliche politikbetrieb ist schon ein
geschmäckle das ist natürlich jetzt alle
sich streiten und alle aus dem urlaub
kommen das sollte sich schämen so
sollten in ihrer stadt genauso mit
gummistiefeln und schaufel und besen
stehen anstatt zu schauen wir stehen
kurz vor den wahlen
armin laschet ritt auf als landesvater
und er will bundeskanzler werden an der
flutkatastrophe stellt sich vielen
menschen die frage nach der ursache der
klimawandel lasse schaut auf das
unfassbare
seine botschaft ich sehe verstehe und
handle
gerade in dieser region werden wir
schneller als das bisher geplant war
kraftwerke schließen die ersten sind
bereits geschlossen
im jahre 2022 werden sieben weitere
braunkohlekraftwerke geschlossen und das
nimmt so viel co2 aus der luft aus dem
was deutschland quasi ausstößt dass wir
damit einen wichtigen baustein gelegt
habe auf einmal wird laschet zum großen
klimaschützer der karten auf dem er
wandelt wenn ihr daraus irgendetwas für
seine wahlkampfkampagne herausziehen
muss muss er es trennen
er hat nichts zu gewinnen gegen werbe
bei der globalen klima frage da hat er
noch keine glaubwürdigkeit die union hat
es auch nicht
für die grünen ist der klimawandel ein
heimspiel deshalb bleibt robert habeck
einfach an der nord und ostsee die grüne
kanzlerkandidaten hält es zu hause dann
doch nicht aus der box fährt in die flut
aber ohne kameras heute bei euch in
rheinland pfalz unterwegs schreibt sie
auf twitter
die gespräche gehen unter die haut den
klimawandel mit sie erst tage später
erwähnen dass es klug den grünen wird
die kompetenz im kampf gegen den
klimawandel zugeschrieben nicht zu
unrecht muss man sagen und ich bin
sicher das thema wird dann nach einer
kleinen pause im wahlkampf wieder eine
rolle spielen und die grünen haben sich
nicht plakativ aufgedrängt glaube das
war eine kluge strategie
politischer tourismus und demonstrierte
tatkraft haben tradition in deutschen
katastrophen 1962 sturmflut in hamburg
ein schneidiger spd innensenator
übernimmt das zepter des handelns helmut
schmidt ein macher ein image das wir
immer bleiben wird oder hochwasser 1997
den jungen brandenburgischen
umweltminister nennen sie den deichgraf
matthias platzeck schafft es zu
bundesweiter bekanntheit damals
unterwegs mit der jungen
bundesministerin merkel wird der deich
kraft bald ministerpräsident und
spd-chef seien im wahlkampf 2002 wartet
gerhard schröder in gummistiefeln durch
das elbhochwasser er schüttelt hände und
findet worte die ihm im wahlkampf nicht
schaden werden was wir brauchen wir sind
uns einig darüber ist eine große
nationale anstrengung das ist nicht eine
sache einer stadt auch nicht die sache
sachsen sondern dass die sache
deutschland herausforderer edmund
stoiber kommt schlicht zu spät wie
glaubhaft wie zynisch sind die flut
auftritte aus heutiger sicht
ich glaube dass bei schmitt überhaupt
kein zynismus damals das war er war ein
solcher politiker er hat pragmatisch
rasch durchgreifend auch etwas autoritär
die probleme gelöst bei schröder weiß
kalkuliert schröder hat einen sensor für
den populistischen moment und er hat den
als populistischen moment genutzt aber
das ist auch etwas verbrauchen und
insofern auch eine gute nachricht dass
damit nicht so beliebig wahlkampf
gemacht werden kann
die frage nach verantwortung und
versäumnissen müssen die beantworten
dies zur katastrophe zieht was wurde
getan um menschen zu warnen was für
ihren schutz
erklärungsversuche wir haben uns ein
hochwasserschutz oben organisiert hier
in der verbandsgemeinde an im aartal
insgesamt sind inzwischen 16 millionen
ausgegeben worden um auch starkregen
ereignisse reagieren zu können und wir
waren eigentlich gut gerüstet aber das
was wir jetzt erlebt haben das hat eine
dimension die wir noch nirgends erlebt
haben
auch der bundesinnenminister kommt und
mit ihm fünf jahrzehnte erfahrung in der
politik hat seinen katastrophenschutz
verwursten einer wie seehofer zu
parieren weiß manches was ich jetzt so
höre muss ich leider einer ganz billigen
wahlkampf rhetorik zu ordnen
das ist fast fertig weil jetzt wirklich
nicht die stunde ist ich sage ich habe
das größte interesse dass wir gemeinsam
die dinge besprechen aufarbeiten aber
jetzt in diesen tagen hat die
bevölkerung ein interesse an der hilfe
und der solidarität noch leichter ist es
die verantwortung von sich dem
klimawandel zuzuschreiben während
wissenschaftler streiten wie groß dessen
einfluss hier wirklich war
treten die politisch verantwortlichen in
einem wahren wettbewerb der einsicht und
erkenntnis
wir spüren dass sich dass der
klimawandel immer stärker auswirkt alle
die das ignorieren die die ihren
fundamental diese starke regen
ereignisse und diese unglaubliche
beschleunigung bei diesen ereignissen
die ist das was eigentlich große sorge
machen wir werden uns dieser naturgewalt
entgegenstemmen kurzfristig aber eben
auch mittel und langfristig durch eine
politik die eben die natur und das klima
mehr in den betracht zieht als wir das
in den letzten jahren gemacht haben auch
das wird notwendig sein
erstaunliche erkenntnisse nach 16 jahren
kanzlerschaft es ist wahlkampf in
deutschland und nicht zum ersten mal
fällt dem eine katastrophe zu es wird
beobachtet wer hier welche figur abgibt
wer hinter dem bundespräsidenten feixt
muss um verzeihung bitten
laschet es auf twitter uns liegt das
schicksal der betroffenen am herzen von
dem wir in vielen gesprächen gehört
haben umso mehr bedaure ich den eindruck
der durch eine gesprächssituation
entstanden ist dies war unpassend und es
tut mir leid
auch heute sind sie wieder da wollen
trost geben und hilfe und dabei das
versäumte am liebsten verschweigen
wahlkampf in der flut die katastrophe
fördert abgründe zu tage in der natur
genauso wie in der politik